[Música]
qual a origem do dinheiro
você já se perguntaram sobre isso
alguém aqui imagina da onde veio essa
criação que a gente utiliza todos os
dias
qual o tempo quanto tempo faz como é que
surgiu quem foi que teve essa brilhante
idéia é uma pergunta que eu comecei a
fazer há cerca de quatro anos e é
impressionante como a gente não faz a
mínima idéia de onde veio algo que está
nos nossos dias é e que faz parte de
toda a nossa vivência diária
essa imagem ilustra um pouco a origem do
dinheiro
ele é tão antigo e tá tão presente na
vida do ser humano que a gente não
consegue nem estimar uma data
muitos pesquisadores estimam que ele
talvez tenha nascido antes da escrita
que a escrita nasceu pra ajudar a fazer
os registros dos fluxos monetários mas
não temos certeza disso
é o que a gente tem certeza é que o
dinheiro é uma forma do ser humano
colocar sua energia em fluxo da gente
comumente social poder se tornar cada
vez mais íntegro e que os recursos que a
gente cria juntos possam circular de
forma abundante
quando a gente começa a perceber o
dinheiro desse lugar
a gente sente como a gente está
desconectado
porque creio eu que muitos aqui não
tenham ouvido falar ainda do dinheiro
desse ponto de vista a gente tem a mania
de olhar para o dinheiro
um pouquinho como essa imagem né a gente
vê dentro de um grande cofre um grande
banco central onde a gente pode tocar
aquilo que a gente precisa para que a
gente possa ter os recursos que a gente
precisa
para sobreviver e é assim que o dinheiro
vem se manifestando nos dias de hoje é
digamos que essa origem de tornar flu
titular em fluxos recursos do ser humano
ela foi sendo fragmentada assim como
conhecimento foi sendo fragmentado assim
como a nossa visão sobre a natureza foi
sendo fragmentada a nossa visão sobre
dinheiro se tornou isso se tornou uma
visão de um grande banco central que a
gente tem que cuidar só para nós ea
gente tem que se tocar a gente poder ter
acesso a ele
a gente não vê ele como um fluxo ea
gente não vê ele como uma forma de os
nossos recursos fluírem criando matei
unificada a minha jornada em olhar o
dinheiro começou com a criação é feita
por esse cara que é um anônimo a gente
não sabe se é um homem uma mulher e um
grupo de pessoas é um anônimo que anc na
internet ele circulou durante três anos
e em 2008 ele criou o que a gente
conhece por bitcoin não sei que muitos
de vocês já ouviram falar quem já ouviu
falar no tal do btt canha legal a minha
jornada entender isso começou com ele
porque quando eu comecei a haver assim
como existe alguém é que lançou na
internet uma moeda criando sua própria
moeda e colocando essa moeda em fluxo
para que todas as pessoas que quisessem
pudesse utilizar dela
isso me pegou né a gente está tão
acostumado a simplesmente ter o dinheiro
vindo do jeito tradicional a moeda real
a única moeda que a gente usa muito ea
gente não entende a origem disse não
entende como é o processo de isso
acontecer e aí quando eu vi uma entidade
um ser anônimo fazer o seu próprio
dinheiro e colocar esse dinheiro em
fluxo foi muito receptivo e eu comecei a
explorar isso eu vivi algumas outras
experiências onde eu passei a criar e eu
criei piso do processo colaborativo onde
eu criei junto de dois grandes amigos
outras três moedas e eu vivenciei isso
na prática
o que eu aprendi e assim que eu acredito
que a gente aprende fazendo na prática
criando muita gente acha que o bitcoin é
só isso né
sobe e desce ganha mais dinheiro
especulando né e se o dinheiro visto
dessa forma a alguns também ficam assim
quando ele não tá ném subindo e descendo
todo mundo fica triste mas ele vai muito
além disso e eu vou trazer um pouquinho
pra vocês do que eu explorei em mim me
conectando com esse olhar que os atores
nakamoto trouxe quando ele criou o
bitcoin criou as chamadas crypton moedas
o que isso despertou em mim porque na
verdade energia do dinheiro é a nossa
energia ela é uma energia externa nós é
a nossa energia que se manifesta que é
colocada no mundo
a primeira coisa é um sistema aberto e
distribuído a forma como a gente encara
o dinheiro hoje ela é extremamente
escassas e anti então a gente tem muito
uma visão de criar intermediários de
criar sistemas fechados que garantam uma
proteção sobre a nossa visão do dinheiro
a gente tenta é impedir que a integração
aconteça
e no caso do bitcoin o sistema é
completamente aberto e distribuído isso
quer dizer o quê que qualquer pessoa que
queira interagir com esse sistema de
dinheiro e sim com essa moeda que foi
criada ela pode interagir não precisa
pedir licença para ninguém
o sistema é totalmente aberto e comum a
todos
qualquer pessoa que tenha a intenção de
fazer isso pode fazer e aí quando eu
olhei pra mim pensando nisso foi muito
paradoxal pensar como eu vejo dinheiro
em mim eu vejo o dinheiro em mim de uma
forma aberta distribuída ou eu crio
estoques eu crio proteção eu crio
maneiras de bloquear o meu fluxo do
dinheiro e e pés com que ele possa fluir
em rede com as pessoas e com os projetos
que relaciona a segunda questão a
neutralidade
o sistema político é neutro é só torcer
que o sistema neutro isso quer dizer o
que é que ele não analisa nenhum tipo de
questão em relação a quem vai usar o que
não vai usar o sistema
é qualquer um está aberto a usá lo então
não tem julgamento dentro do sistema ele
é completamente neutro para que ele seja
neutro
então ninguém é o juiz diz cada um é o
juiz de si mesmo é o nosso sistema de
dinheiro atual ele é extremamente
bloqueado ele tem juízes e pessoas que
bloqueiam o seu processo de acesso ele
não tem uma neutralidade mas olhando pra
nós mesmos a coisa fica ainda mais
profunda é qual é o nosso olhar sobre
isso né
a gente consegue ter uma neutralidade em
relação a como agente livre ou as
emoções que se manifestam quando a gente
está mexendo com essa energia do
dinheiro são completamente egóicos ou se
manifestam de outras formas
a gente consegue a isso de um lugar
neutro a gente consegue ver essa energia
fluindo com neutralidade
o terceiro ponto os intermediários
essa moeda flui no sistema sem
intermediários isso quer dizer o que é
que se eu quiser fazer um fluxo de valor
com essa moeda o fluxo monetário entre
eu e uma pessoa que está lá na china por
exemplo eu consiga enviar isso
diretamente para ela não tem nenhuma
entidade no meio não tem um banco o
banco central e tudo mais nenhuma
empresa não tem nada envolvido então ele
criou um sistema de moeda que permite
com que a moeda flu sem intermediários
a gente também tem essa grande questão é
nós gostamos de ter intermediários que
garantam a segurança do nosso próprio
fluxo
a gente sempre quer tirar de nós a
responsabilidade a gente gosta de tirar
a responsabilidade pra que a gente não
tenha não assumir o nosso lugar em
relação a isso e assim que a sociedade
vai perdendo potência e nós vamos
perdendo potência em relação a esse
fluxo sem censura
o sistema de dinheiro ligado ao beach
com ele não tem censura no sentido de
que ninguém pode barrar o fluxo que
acontece na rede como no modelo
tradicional por exemplo você pode ter
sua conta bloqueada você pode ter um
o fluxo monetário que você quis realizar
travado
então ele tem uma certa censura
envolvendo esse sistema
nesse sistema não toda a transação
acontece sem nenhum tipo de análise é
uma rede automática que faz isso mas o
que interessa olhar do ponto que eu
trazendo pra vocês como nós nos
censuramos em relação a isso
em relação à energia do dinheiro nós
censuramos muito a gente vive um
conflito interno enorme em relação a
isso né
em relação a como olhar para esse
processo a gente não consegue se
integrar e viver uma relação íntegra com
a energia do dinheiro que nós temos que
colocar para fluir em comunidade sem
fronteiras
essa é uma das grandes revoluções que
vem acontecendo na minha opinião é essa
está essa nova moeda que nasceu com os
atores como eu coloquei e que agora já
se espalhou pelo mundo de várias outras
formas para derrubar as fronteiras que
existem no fluxo monetário é como o
whatsapp fez com as comunicações na
internet que hoje em dia você consegue
conversar com qualquer pessoa do mundo
sem custo e alcançar qualquer tipo de
pessoa que você queira isso agora está
disponível com o dinheiro também né o
fluxo monetário agora também pode fluir
sem fronteira
é o dinheiro da internet é esse dinheiro
ele veio pra suprir uma necessidade de
enviar fluxos pela internet
voltando a nós mesmos que há um grande
centro da conversa aqui
quanto às fronteiras a gente tem em
relação a isso
quantos bloqueios nós criamos em nosso
ambiente para obstruir o fluxo com medo
de que esse fluxo aconteça que a gente
acha que vai faltar
se a gente derrubar essas fronteiras que
existem entre nós e outro a gente fazia
isso cotidianamente a transparência
essa moeda criada pelos atores ela
trouxe transparência completa o sistema
diferente do modelo que a gente vive na
moeda tradicional nessa manhã ela tem
todo o seu registo seus registros
abertos
qualquer um pode ver o que acontece no
sistema mas quando a gente olha pra
gente nesse ponto é como a gente pode
ser transparente com nós mesmos sobre a
nossa relação com o dinheiro
que transparência que a gente tem é a
gente simplesmente deixa e se escondido
e não encara isso de frente
foi assim que eu comecei a ver a moeda
desse ponto de vista da moeda em rede e
essa moeda em rede ela tem alguns
fenômenos interessantes acontecendo no
mundo
quando a gente começa a incorporar esse
olhar derrubando essas fronteiras
alguns fenômenos começam a acontecer
nesses me perdoem os as nomenclaturas
porque em português a gente tem uma
dificuldade tradição desses termos então
class tem esse é um movimento natural
que acontece quando a rede começa a se
formar
então tudo pode emergir de forma
autônoma e livre onde as pessoas vão se
juntando e criando coisas estão hoje em
dia a gente tem é mais ou menos 3 mil
moedas já sendo criadas dentro desse
sistema de crédito de krypton moedas já
tem outros vindo mas isso a
clusterização está acontecendo está
sendo muito rápida
as moedas comunitárias já fazem isso mas
com a crypton isso tá ficando ainda mais
forte
o suor mim que é o movimento de as
pessoas se juntam para fazer um grande
movimento coletivo como a gente viu nas
manifestações aqui no brasil isso com a
escrita moedas e com a moeda em rede
está ganhando cada vez mais potência nós
já temos milhões de usuários espalhados
pelo mundo
vivendo uma realidade de um novo olhar
sobre as moedas
o clone é quando a gente copia o nosso
companheiro a pessoa que está na nossa
ciclo de interação e integra padrões
novos para o que está sendo criado de
uma forma coletiva então eu quero aquilo
que o meu vizinho está fazendo copiou
ele mas não copio exatamente igual eu
coloco uma coisa única que é só minha e
o sistema ganha mais valor ainda
integrando essa coisa única que eu
coloquei isso vai se espalhando de um
clã tim que é o amassamento do mundo é
as fronteiras diminuindo no mundo
é com a internet todo mundo já senti
isso diariamente né a gente já já sente
que o mundo está muito pequeno
agora com o sistema financeiro e senão
não vinha acontecendo
mas esse movimento chegou então agora a
gente já pode experience ao mundo onde
as barreiras de circulação do fluxo
monetário elas estão cada vez menores e
cada vez com um custo mais baixo é é a
experiência que a gente vive a
comunicação está chegando no no dinheiro
mas o que que é a grande questão por
trás disso é eu acho que a gente tem que
começar a ver o dinheiro é não mais como
as popularmente conhecida moeda corrente
talvez a gente tenha que ver como uma
correnteza que possa fluir não fique
presa então a gente tem que olhar mais
isso do ponto de vista da água que flui
e o que pode fazer esse processo se
potencializar a gente olhar pro dinheiro
como um bem comum com um bem comum que
não tem propriedade
ele é de todo mundo mas ao mesmo tempo
não é de propriedade de ninguém e é
assim que funciona essa moeda e assim
foram as moedas que a experiência e isso
é muito positivo sem processo de seleção
eliminar tudo o que a gente tem em nós
mesmos
a nossa ideia de que é preciso
selecionar as coisas boas para que algo
aconteça e deixar que a livre interação
selecione naturalmente aquilo que
precisa emergir é derrubar todas as
barreiras que separam o nosso processo
interativo e deixar com que a auto
organização e com a organização humana
aconteça e possa florescer sem cadeia de
comando e controle
ou seja eliminar essa idéia de controlar
o fluxo natural da vida
o fluxo ele sempre é abundante ele não
escasseia nunca somos nós que criamos
processos onde a gente tenta controlar
isso
e são esses processos que geram uma
escassez sistêmica
quando a gente se liberta do controle a
vida pode fluir através de nós e ela
pode se manifestar em todo o mundo que
está interagindo
sistema os encargos padrões
principalmente em nós mesmos vamos
eliminar todas as barreiras possíveis
que a gente cria em nós de que a gente
precisa ser especialista de alguma coisa
só pode atuar em nossas especialidades
nós temos todas as capacidades humanas
para exercer tudo aquilo que a gente
queira exercer a gente pode criar tudo
que a gente quiser criar mas não somos
tolidos a um cargo e o ser humano não é
um padrão ser humano é algo único e a
gente tem que manifestar essa nossa
unicidade para que a gente possa se
libertar esses padrões sem caixa
centralizado e orçamento centralizado
não vamos mais centralizar a energia que
a gente quer fazer fluir e estagnar
esse processo isso vem acontecendo com o
dinheiro e isso tem que acontecer com
nós mesmos
a gente tem que derrubar essas barreiras
que centraliza o fluxo de energia e
eliminar os processos coletivos de
tomada de decisão isso não quer dizer
que a gente vai parar de convivem redes
de conviver de forma coletiva isso quer
dizer que a gente pode exercer a nossa
responsabilidade e atuar da forma que a
gente quiser sem precisar pedir
permissão para ninguém
a gente pode tomar todas as decisões
únicas que nós queremos tomar sem
precisar pedir com que o outro me
autorize e eu a realizar aquilo que eu
quero
integrando esses aspectos a gente começa
a olhar o mundo ea vida de um outro
ponto de vista
a gente deixa essa visão mecânica que
está tão incorporado à nossa consciência
está tão incorporado no nosso olhar
sobre vários aspectos mas em especial
aqui trazendo a mensagem sobre o
dinheiro ea gente começa a ver esse
fluxo em nós mesmos vindo de um outro
ponto
vindo de um ponto muito mais íntegro e
muito mais abundante onde isso não fui
como uma máquina e sim como um campo de
energia
que está fluindo através de nós e vocês
já pensaram como seria criar sua própria
moeda em rede
obrigado
[Aplausos]